[Applause]
i don't know why i went like that that
made no sense for me i thought your legs
oh did you
how do you feel
okay i'm glad that you guys called me
considering i busted my face open yeah
damn
i know son you can't even see it in my
left eye how's that doing everybody it's
good it's not too bad oh dude you can't
even tell it's a tiny little scar
you spin bro i spin a little bro how
many spms you clock that up this one's
about 72. so brett there's no one that
takes a harder fall in our videos than
you even when we don't ask you to do it
you still do it and you like you commit
really hard but you always get up at the
end thankfully so i was wondering if you
could share with myself and everybody
else watching how do you take a fall
without hurting yourself
oh my god dude freaking flying zombie
what is your secret i know you grew up
skateboarding doing a lot of that but i
want to learn a little bit about this
this technique how about you're just
minding your own business one day
but you have this rare disease that
causes you to turn into a rag doll once
in a while okay and so spontaneously
you'll just rag doll
i'll come back to the ground basically
my knees collapse that you start with
your knees collapsing
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is that all right let's
try it so all right start with your
knees basically you keep your your legs
straight and then just start with like a
little bend and once you feel that bend
you kind of just like how do you avoid
hitting your head
you just hold like it rim
you don't stiff your neck but you just
keep it loose and just up a bit you
didn't put your hand out at all or
anything like that well i trust myself i
think that's the thing too is trust and
knowing how your body's gonna fall
before you actually fall
how do you feel i feel i feel great
yo nico in his quest to make the perfect
battlegrounds video one of the
characters has a really unique sped
snatch helmet it's a russian special
forces bulletproof helmet this is an old
beekeeper's mask this is an airsoft
helmet and then i've got this visor from
this janky fireman's hat basically i'm
going to put them all together cover
this with something starts to work i'm
gonna work with what we got here and
make a janky spet's nuts helmet so you
probably already know this but we are
selling some incredible peter 42 teas
designed by a fran drew they're also in
baseball tee style as well also uh good
news we upgraded our shirts into this
incredible nice durable thick hanes
t-shirt cotton and uh it makes the print
last a lot longer on these shirts now
we're really excited to start carrying
these for all our shirts
so right let's say you're uh reminding
your own business and you get sniped
okay
yeah let's see let's get two heads and
see what shoulder hit and you're like
what and then head shot okay shoulder
head
oh you're gonna shoot it nick all right
damn
dude that just like straight flat to the
ground how did you land on your back
like solid like that without getting the
wind knocked out this isn't soft either
i guess i just trust myself enough to
hit when i hit just to kind of absorb it
with my back too i'm using my my lower
back as well when i hit you're staying
pretty relaxed pretty relaxed yeah so
shoulder
and then head
but i'm not hitting like
is there a special technique you use
like how do you not keep from just like
breaking your ankles and collapsing to
the ground when you roll yeah roll
i don't it's using your back and your
shoulder really um like your shoulder
goes in first and then your back rolls
man so you're spreading the impact out
over a lot of your body and also making
your mind continue forwards so a lot of
the energy doesn't actually get absorbed
it actually continues if i was to try
falling on my back like you did where
you just
kicked out and said landing on the back
okay it's always good to have two shots
for me if you're hitting a shoulder you
get a shot and you still use that
momentum from this
to throw yourself backwards
you're going down
well
let me give it a shot
i don't know if you guys know this but
the quarter digital format of making
viral short films isn't supported on
youtube at all i mean yes a little bit
people enjoy them people enjoy them we
love making them but it's not like our
main source of revenue we do it because
we love it now i'm going to drill some
pilot holes
this just comes off too so i can work on
that separately
my regulations i need a 25 of course
it's not here why would it be here where
is the line every nail is right here by
the way so you can hang [ __ ] don't get
me wrong i love everybody here but
sometimes working here
is like working with a bunch of
teenagers
all right we're in business now i'll put
the lining back in and then i will work
on a piece to cover this
so that you get a solid
plate
are you ready
how do you feel i landed on my side more
than my back i kind of chickened out on
the back hit
chicken now right now you're landing at
like a 45 degree angle and then going
down where's the trick is you actually
got to land flat
that was a lot better all right i still
put my hands down you bet you landed
flat this time if i didn't quite land on
my shoulders like brett instructed me
too i feel okay i need to try not to
stop myself with my hands that doesn't
do anything it just makes the fall look
shitty
i'm doing something like that
i'm gonna be sniped
what's your method
wing it i always treat it like like like
a light punch you know like
i keep my body a little loose too so
you're able to do that kind of stuff so
and then i use this as you push back
you
know all right is there a sniper around
how do you feel
don't feel good at all
you like didn't relax at all that was so
intense that was like the worst thing to
do
i got to do it i got to do that again
i could never do that i think it was i
didn't exhale when i crashed my whole
body just are you breathing are you
tense i was tense all right
you were around the back was that man i
got i gotta arch my back more it was not
it's not too much like that you'll
probably break something just just
slight you know like just very light
sarah you want a sniper
so
see i'm landing on my right side rather
than flat on my back
up at the
oh
oh my god these guys did a number on
this blade dude
we're gonna have to replace that blade
every time i go to find something
what are you looking for now just a
pencil that i keep in here
there's a pencil by your foot
this isn't it but
it'll do
huh that's where it goes
check this out
ready my hands empty
i'll go under the table
and pick up oh dude yeah that's where
the glue goes i might sound like i'm
just complaining which i kind of am
having a clean workshop where it's not
yeah it's all of these tools are really
expensive people don't really understand
like
like this is a this is a hundred and
twenty dollar
power drill
it's like a hundred dollar jigsaw you
have thousands of dollars worth of
equipment in here you know i've tried
multiple different ways to get people to
pay more attention to it but
at least we got the camera room a little
bit more figured out
look in the time that it takes the glue
gun to heat up i bet you i can clean up
half of this workshop
you're on dude
yeah we filmed all these shirt pushers
on one day and guess what you got one
day left to get these peter 42 shirts as
well so if you haven't gotten one yet or
are interested check out quarter
digital.com store we're also selling
these in an incredible baseball tee
style as well screen printed so check
them out before they're gone
we're talking about walls did you really
like running into walls that's fun okay
yeah all right let's create situations i
think situations help me better too so
you guys come around the corner and nico
stops here and blasts the zombie that's
pursuing him
my name is lance masterson uh a trucker
turned survivor when the world was
infected but it didn't affect me because
i was in my truck now i've been
searching this gas station for food
hey man you okay
oh dude are you all right brett i'm good
son
dude the extra flop at the end so good
did i do this
no okay having something to react off of
when doing stunts like for me it's that
extra like initiative to actually do it
you know so i noticed like when you came
at the wall you didn't just hit the wall
you sold the stunt on how hard you flung
everything up to the wall so it's like
you snapped your hair back you snapped
your arms you made it look like you were
basically struck by lightning flop down
to the ground and when you hit the
ground i also noticed that you did the
kind of same thing and get struck by
lightning again where like when you hit
the ground you sold the impact by
flicking everything again yeah
definitely two impacts so you can
definitely react off off of it like
especially when i hit the ground i'm
able to kind of you know do an extra
roll out of it you know like land on my
face or something so i feel like i
should take what i learned and be the
zombie this time okay i'm down to shoot
you
[Music]
there's half of the there's half the
workshop
glue gun's not even hot yet
someone's gonna [ __ ] saw their hands
off with this thing i know it
carbon fiber
glue gun's hot there's still some spray
paint on the ground i'll admit
how long did that take
five minutes
cool part one
sweet i got the grand big globs of the
greasy grammy i got the greasy grandma
go for guts and my grammy don't get your
grimy guts on my grammy
pretty good
hey man you good
that's actually a really good one that
was really i did it how does it feel i
felt fine i just i just kind of tried to
explode everything before i hit the wall
and then actually
pushed off all of my hand
um so i flew myself off it and like spin
down to the ground
sounds good so what i think could really
sell is that impact of the bullet yeah i
didn't do the first one very well my hit
on the ground was good but my first
bullet impact wasn't any good i was
basically like just getting ready for
this move and like did that
[Music]
nice look
yeah all the all the different
techniques all right brett well
hopefully you saved some people's
injury hopefully if they slip on ice or
something like that they're like
just like a character and like commit
and also like
no sim card no sim card so
peter has been using this sony phone
since his film broke
and i just found
buried away in the cable box in the
equipment room
a broken phone and these these are our
phones that we have here i thought peter
broke in hit on him
that was not me it was not him it was
not peter but someone broke
one of the studio phones and hid it in a
cable box
we have a we have a mystery we have an
investigation on our hands did
fingerprints oh no you call it tainted
it was actually spotless really when i
found it
they went down they wiped it
it's professional dude get your hat in
magnifying glass we gotta miss you to
solve peter
me